tiens bon jour c'est une chaleur
terrible aujourd'hui je m'en serais bien
une glace au chocolat
il faut que je termine mon travail
d'abord kazim kazim et y avoir est ce
que tu peux mon un service qui signe à
wen wei alors eh bien tu vas voir
sabrina et de lui demande pour moi un
corner bien ce chocolat ouais ouais avec
beaucoup de motards enfin casimir à la
il vraiment besoin pour aimer la glace
au chocolat avec de la moutarde
bon bon bon bon mais d'accord à la avec
des anchois et puis des capots pas de
cap pas de choix et pas de 4,9 à bon bon
bon
et même pas un petit peu de mayonnaise
casimir un cornet de glace au chocolat
un point c'est tout bon bon compris par
pis pour toi merci on va y aller
tavernier laurent qui vient avec moi on
va aller chercher qu'une glace pour
françois un bon jour sabrina dont jean
casimir
quelle chaleur aujourd'hui que puis-je
pour toi j'ai bien on voudrait un cornet
de glace pour françois oui quel parfum
halle au chocolat c'est un au chocolat
au chocolat mais alors sans moutarde 100
400 en choix et même pas de mayonnaise
ne t'inquiète pas casimir je sais que
françois n'a pas les mêmes goûts que toi
voilà voilà bon merci on vient laurent
vous avez entendu il n'y a vraiment que
casimir pour aimer la glace au chocolat
avec de la moutarde des anchois ou de la
mayonnaise
sabrina oui regarde regarde
c'est une glace oui il ya quelqu'un qui
a fait tomber sa gaffe tout chocolat
tu viens viens de porter la sienne à
françois ouais ouais ouais
oui les enfants venez voir
on lui promet bien voir l'un de vous
at-il fait tomber sa glace
non à écouter casimir viennent porter
une glace à france soir j'en ai vendu
une tout à l'heure à monsieur du snob
il y à une heure il fait très chaud
le facteur est venu me chercher une il
ya une demi heure je me demande bien
lequel a pu faire tomber sa glace vous
voyez pas pourtant elle aurait fondu
fait très chaud voyez pas qui ça peut
être c'est quelqu'un qui est venu la
chercher il n'ya pas longtemps
non tu vois pas qui est venu en chercher
une un dernier casimir alors c'est
qu'être casimir vient voir tu es sûr que
ce n'est pas toi qui a fait tomber cette
glace écoute sabrina j'ai honte j'ai
menti mais je savais bien que c'était
moi puis c'est et françois alors en mai
françois tu sais alors là je lui ai
porté hier la place quelque chose de
très très beaux que casimir oye mba que
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que cette
horreur que dumas a donné à manger je
vais m'y oppose au nez mais mais mais
c'est très bon tout ça c'est fidèle à
ses trios de marron avec des petits
cornichons dans un petit peu c'est très
bon quid alors